it is November 9 2022 and you're
watching the code report since the dawn
of man the high Priests of civilization
have prophesized chaos destruction and
change following a blood moon or lunar
eclipse like the one we saw yesterday
today it's becoming clear that those
prophecies are 100 correct now this is a
learn to code Channel and I like to be
positive and optimistic but I think it's
also important to be honest about the
short-term headwinds facing attack right
now becoming a programmer has never been
easy but I think it'll be even harder
for the next year or two today meta
announced layoffs of over 11 000
employees and that's pretty huge when
you compare it to Twitter's layoffs of 3
700 employees last week that's mostly
due to Zuckerberg's bad bets on the
metaverse and ridiculous spending to go
along with it meta the company is going
to be fine they're still very profitable
and have tons of cash but if you're
looking for a faying job in 2022 you
might want to take the F out of the
equation you can also remove the a
because apple and Amazon have
implemented hiring freezes Google and
Netflix are still viable options as of
today and then the missing Fang member
Microsoft also recently implemented
layoffs so they might be out of the
question for a while too but most people
don't work at Fang there's a lot of
other tech companies to consider
unfortunately they're also getting
hammered and we're seeing layoffs there
as well Robin Hood cut 23 Intel cut 20
Snapchat 20 coinbase 18 lift 13 and even
stripe just laid off 14 of its Workforce
and there are many others that you can
check out on layoffs.fyi a website that
keeps track of all this stuff as you can
see in 2021 there were almost no layoffs
and now we've seen huge increases
throughout the entirety of 2022. in
addition many of the companies that went
public are down anywhere from 50 to 95
percent like upstart and AI lending
platform has gone from over 300 a share
to just 15 a share or a firm the buy now
pay later company has also collapsed
more than 90 percent it's all starting
to look like the.com bubble 2.0
everything went to hell when the FED
started raising interest rates to fight
inflation but inflation is still almost
just as bad as it was before which means
these high interest rates are going to
be around for a while and that's bad for
tech companies that operate at a loss
because they need access to the the easy
money to finance things like new hires
nobody wants to do layoffs they're a
last resort but things may get worse
before they get better and then there's
Tom
Kowski
he's useless
useless go on in fact I just got news
that Salesforce is planning a big layoff
now Friedman the CEO of GitHub recently
said that many tech companies are 2 to
10 times overstaffed and everyone who's
paying attention already knows this and
your startup has access to easy money
it's easier to just hire more people
than to fire the low performers the
typical Mantra is grow or die if your
user base and Workforce is growing it
really doesn't matter how much money
you're losing if you play your cards
right eventually you'll get acquired or
IPO to let someone else hold the bag in
many cases it's not much unlike a Ponzi
scheme you have the founders and early
investors like Venture capitalists
sitting at the top of the pyramid they
try to make the company grow really fast
while not making money to attract more
investors to pour more money into it
finally when you go public you can
unload your shares like the founders of
coinbase did before the stock plummets
nearly 90 percent a year later the
losers at the bottom of the pyramid are
institutional and Retail investors who
bought into the hype now this isn't
always the case and sometimes you do
have really great companies that go on
to make money and change the world but
what we're going to do is get rid of all
these buttons
and just make a giant screen but it's
important to understand how the game is
played if you're a programmer you're
just a pawn in this game however pawns
can be very important none of these
companies are going to be firing their
top Engineers software engineering is at
the very core of what most of them do
those jobs are only going away when the
company goes bankrupt so I think the key
to doing well in this job market is to
be hard working and or be really good at
what you do and remember this is only a
phase caused by the recent lunar eclipse
luckily on April 8 2024 a solar eclipse
will happen at which point the FED will
pivot to usher in the next cycle of
irrational exuberance this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one
[Music]